the Pixie video in 2023. He actually signed an affidavit as well
that said that he had never sent it after the 2022 date like
and he said it in no uncertain terms that I've never done that
ever. Right. I absolutely have not done that. And he signed an
affidavit. Yeah. So that's basically like uh I will testify to
this fact if you if required. Can he be tried for some form of
perjury for if that's under penalty of perjury? Yes. Same with
Aby's the beginning. I don't really know how this ties together,
but we'll be able to walk through it. So, Pixie, two days ago,
one day ago says, "Good news. Despite opposition from Destiny's
Council, the court has granted us the ability to keep witnesses
under uh identity witnesses identities under seal." Hold on.
Pixie versus Destiny on
Twitter. I'm updating my titles cuz why not? Why not update the
titles? Okay, so let's go through. Let's take a look. Kelly,
good news. Despite opposition from Destiny's Council, the court
has granted us the ability to keep witnesses identity under seal.
If you have any information regarding the case, we can file to
keep your name out of the public and protected by the court.
Please don't hesitate to contact me if you believe you might
be a witness or another victim. Please help donate if you can
to help to keep this case going. Every dollar counts. Uh, so
the first thing I see from most people who are totally who are
just the drags of society is people will go and say like um they'll
go and complain about this. I don't know if I see one here. This
guy's a total um but I don't know if I see one necessarily, but
I see a whole bunch of people going like you shouldn't discuss
this in public. Which is really really funny. Oh, people who
are like, "OMG, he's pro. Why is dope communicating with Destiny?"
Uh, I don't know why she's communicating with Destiny. I would
ask if is Destiny communicating with her cuz I feel like she
tweeted this, right? Pretty sure he started that, too.
Uh, in any case, in any case, Pixie is trying to fund a case.
She does not have the money to pay, right? She's literally collecting
donations. That is the whole entire purpose of what she is doing.
She's collecting donations, right? So, everybody who's like,
"Wait, why is she talking about this?" Because she needs money
to actually fund this case. Do you understand? Do you understand?
She is out of money. She needs money. Money makes the world go
round, kids. Okay, that's what she's doing. She's trying to fund
raise. So, what the guy said? How why is D talking to Destiny?
And I could have sworn Destiny had quote tweeted her, but maybe
not. Maybe maybe that didn't happen. Maybe he uh didn't do that.
Stop talking in public. Yeah, people are like, "Yeah, don't talk
about this in public. You shouldn't fight in public." Okay, so
Destiny quote tweeted her or actually I guess took a picture
of her tweet. So, I don't know why Destiny is talking to D first.
Wouldn't that actually go in the other direction? Uh, yeah, Vigilance
Stream, I think I agree with you, but I think what we talked
about, what you showed me was the I can't remember if it was
a federal rule of civil procedure or if it was the local rules,
but there was an exception saying like if you have reason to
believe that releasing those names to opposing council could
actually cause harm, you can make that argument. But I think
by default, you are violating the rules. And then you'd have
to basically tell the judge, "This is why we think there should
be an exemption here." I actually looked it up. It's the
26C one. And that is a federal thing, not a not a local rule.
Federal rules. And that's the exception that they were asking
for quite early on as well, you can find reference to it. And
basically like Destiny's lawyers try to argue against it, which
is fine, but they obviously weren't compelling enough. So that's
why um Pixie's Council was granted it as far as I can tell. It's
like there's not like one specific thing people use always for
this exception, but the 26 C is what they did use. How can I
I think I want to look for like a little F like this rules 26F.
Are we in F right now? We're not Why it's applicable right here.
Conference of the parties planning for discovery reasons disclosure.
Uh, I don't know if this is it necessarily. Vigilant stream,
you sent it to me. And I think Destiny asked for the motion to
be denied on those grounds. Doesn't make sense because the court
can remedy by granting Pixie's motion and giving Destiny the
info at the same time, which is what happened. Well, and that's
also I just like pointing out that that's exactly what Pixie's
council said. It's like, hey, this is probably going to be granted
and then we will give you all of this stuff anyway. Like, we'll
file it through the court and you'll have it, right? I would
assume that what would probably happen is if if those declarations
were sufficiently like um were sufficiently like eye opening
were sufficient I I don't know sufficiently suspicious the judge
would allow those people to be questioned. That's why the whole
thing like blowing this up as if it was a big deal from the beginning
always seemed weird to me. It's like the judge will literally
just say what should happen, right? I read it um and cuz I people
got mad because I was using chat GBT but chat GBT is just a tool
if I'm inputting the files PDF files from a court case and the
judge's ruling on why and then they relate it to the specific
um legal doctrine which is like a 26 C one that they're referring
to is like a type of protective order. Yeah. And that can be
used to Yeah. allows courts to limit prevent discovery disclosure
to protect party or persons from annoyance, embarrassment, oppression,
or undue burden or expense. And yeah, it's used to seal names
and statements when disclosure poses significant risk. And they
just have to show good cause, which is what the judge ruled good
cause. It it says that right in the ruling. Um, so the judge
decided that Pixie Council made a good enough argument to use
that. So I don't know. It's not like Destiny's side for whatever
reason has tried to say they can't use the 26C1 because it's
usually they were trying to like imply that it should only narrowly
be used in Discovery, but it's like apparently it's quite frequently
used outside of Discovery as well. And I'm sure Destiny's lawyers
knew that and still made that argument. Anyway, that's probably
surprised. Just want to cut it stream. Can you link what you
link before the exemption? Do you mind linking that, please?
I can't remember the link.
I'm I He I don't think I don't know if what you're linking me
is what he links me. He linked me something that was like uh
I I thought it was outside of this. Maybe not. It's possibly
not. But um just I understand they made that argument. 37 C.
Is it in the same thing?
Rule rule. Oh, hold on. It should be right there. 37, right?
Undersc_37.
Rule 37 C. Cooperate in discovery sanctions. So, to compel a
discovery, relate to a deposition. Wait, hold on. C as in C here.
Whoops. Failure to disclose a supple to supplement an earlier
response or to admit. Uh, so C rule 37 C. Rule 26A.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. fails to identify a witness as
required by rule 26A or E. Uh, thank you to whoever that was.
I missed it. Sorry. I'll go through this in just a second. I'm
just trying to get to where what I'm looking at. Yeah. The party
is not allowed to use that information or witness to supply evidence
on a motion or at hearing. So, essentially, um, this wouldn't
be evidence the judge would take into account for the motion.
I think Destiny is taking like a lot of the, um, the filings
and he's like, "This is this wouldn't be fair to put in front
of a jury." And I would like possibly agree that without the
identity there, without knowing the identity, that would be crazy
to put in front of a jury. But like in terms of making the motion,
I like it's not going to be evidence that can be put in front
of the judge. It won't be relevant to the motion unless
um unless they provide the identity. Why would they be? So the
motion has to be granted and they file the stuff. Oh, I'm just
saying that like he's he's acting like there's a great injustice
being done, but I don't think there's a massive injustice being
done.
um he's he's upset that basically they're filing something and
people can look at that publicly, right? And and that like that
affects his reputation and then if it if it doesn't go through,
the seal doesn't go through, then the identities aren't known.
But it's like I just I don't know. I don't know if that like
if I I would basically just trust a judge to make a ruling on
that. Like the judge would say, "Okay, you guys actually have
put something out here that's crazy. He should have the right
to like I don't know, question that person." Well, the judge
made already made a decision. I don't um well the judge hasn't
made a decision on a couple things basically. I think whether
or not they'd want to sanction uh like Pixie's lawyers I don't
think the judge has made any decision on that right and I'm sure
Destiny's team will argue something. Um there's no indication
that they will but I think I think it's broadly acknowledged
that they didn't necessarily follow the rules of civil procedure
like but they have a reason for it and there is some exemption
in here as well. The exception is this. What the the the No,
sorry. There's maybe you you can link it to me. Sure. Kelly.
Also, Destiny constantly says that you have the right to confront
witnesses invoking the Sixth Amendment confrontation clause when
it doesn't apply to civil cases. He's only protected by the rules
of discovery and evidence. Oh, interesting. Yeah, it's like under
the court's discretion for rule 26 C, but like the exception
that they were asking for, they asked for quite a while ago.
Oh, I don't know why there's this weird implication that they
hadn't asked for this exceptional. Made it clear what they were
doing. Oh, by the way, if anyone wants to come argue, you can
hop in Oh, yeah. You can hop in Collins in the Discord. God damn
it. Uh, we can argue after this. I don't like law. It's annoying.
So, like I just uh it's just funny and it like bothers me to
see like Destiny tell Pixie she doesn't know what she's talking
about when she has a degree. Well, she has three degrees and
one of them's in law and he's an uneducated buffoon who washed
carpets for a living. I just The audacity of the male is ridiculous.
Okay. Um, yeah, sure.
So, are you, Kelly? Well, no. I do have an education. It's better
than his considering he doesn't have one.
What am I looking for here? Vigilant stream. It's whatever you
linked me the other day that I we looked at something the other
day and that was like I'm not the one putting down in the thing
she has the degree in. Am I? Uh I don't Does Bixy have a degree
in law or something? What's going on there? She has It's like
um she has I think three. I want to say it was law
philosophy. What was the other one? Oh, Cavesi. Thank you for
the primer. Could have been politics. Wait, I don't think I have
no idea. So, I don't see this one in here. Uh, so here we'll
we'll just go through it. Failure to disclose to supplement an
earlier response or to admit failure to disclose or supplement.
If the party fails to provide information or identify a witness
as required by rule 26A or E, the party is not allowed to use
that information or witness to supply evidence on a motion, at
a hearing or at a trial unless the failure was substantially
justified or is harmless. Oh, maybe this was it substantially
justified. So, basically, their failure to identify this person,
they have a justification for that, right? And so this this right
here this is a part of how they would actually like get mad at
you. Failure to make disclosures or to cooperate in discovery
and sanctions. So it's basically like if you could substantially
justify why you failed to follow the rules and the judge agrees
then it can be they can just go
Yeah. So that is it.
Uh that was what straight was telling Destiny. Yeah. Okay. All
right. This was it actually. Okay. So, back to the tweets. So,
Pixie tweeted that out and then apparently Destiny decided to
respond. Since DO is posting misinformation about this, just
to clarify, the issue I have is opposing council filing redacted
declarations without making the unredacted versions available
to me. Thankfully, the court has said they need to file the unredacted
versions under seal. Now, that was always what they plan to do.
That was what Pixie's lawyers literally told you they were going
to do, and you soyed the out about it cuz you're very legally
educated. Yes. This was specifically they said, "This is what
we're going to do." And now he's like, they said, "This is exactly
what we're going to do. When when you when the court rules in
the motion, we will file the unredacted copies with the court
and that then the court will make them available to you through
like Pacer, right? You you'll be able to access them. Good luck."
And now Destiny's like, "Yes, the thing that I freaked the out
about when they sent that email." Yeah. That I pulled up on my
stream and actually got mad about. Now that that's happened.
Ah, yes. This is exactly what I wanted. I this guy is so like
uh like narrativerained, so framing that he's actually like totally
breaking. His memory has failed completely. Doesn't remember
what he was saying before. He's just like, "No, no, no. This
is exactly what I was expecting to have happen." Okay. All right.
I truthfully I have no idea like the the dregs of society that
must look at what this guy says and take him seriously anymore.
It's very sad. Uh to be clear, that is just for impositions of
sanctions. They still failed to follow the local rules. Yeah,
I agree with you, Vigilant Stream. I think it's pretty hard to
argue against contemporaneously identity or unredacted copies
should be served to opposing council. OMGs Pro just sent a paragraph.
It starts with I just don't understand. I I know that's mostly
how I feel about you most of the time. OMFG's bro. I just don't
understand Pixie's reason for talking about the case. Fundraising
fundraising fundraising fundraising fundraising fundraising fundraising
fundraising. I don't know if you know this, but just posting
a GoFundMe does not fund raise. You need to actually do something.
You need to actually talk to people. You need to actually have
some kind of like content or thing you're giving people so that
they're interested. Ethany has a reason to talk about the case
for two reasons. Not that I agree with them. One of them is reputation
rehab. Okay. The other one to make content. Pixie is literally
Pixie is literally doing the making content part of this. Unfortunately,
she she can't just like ask her family to like mortgage their
house or something. That would be that would be stupid. That
would be silly. That'd be goofy. Anyway, okay. So, since Yeah.
I it's weird that he he's like try kind of just tried to change
what his position was. I do agree that like in the um in the
case where they could file things and say, "Okay, well actually
like Destiny and murdered a girl in 1996, we have an affidavit
from somebody and then that doesn't get to file under seal and
now they go, oh, actually never mind. Remove that from the record."
Okay. I think I think that would be crazy, right? That would
be totally insane. That would be beyond the pale. Desi would
have to be able to question that person to make sure that they're
operating legitimately and not just making things up about him,
right? I totally agree. In that case, the identities being withheld
from him are absurd. Okay, I would totally agree that would be
absurd. But again, I'm just positive a judge would know that
and would just go, "Oh, you actually have to provide him the
identities." Like he's concerned that you've asked these people
to perjure themselves, which he said multiple times, by the way.
He has said, "Yes, these people perjured themselves. These people
are just lying and they're making things up now."
Okay. Too much good faith because he does know who these people
are. Well, he knows who the most important one of discovery back
to them. Sure. He knows who they all are. I'm sure he's just
pretending like he doesn't. He said he doesn't know who one is
and I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. Search his logs and figure
it out. I don't think any of them would be difficult. They all
have identifying information in them, don't they? Uh, most of
them do. I believe they do. Yes, Kelly. That's why he's full
of or early onset Alzheimer's. Whichever the two, Destiny, I
don't care. Anyway, yeah. Oh, also for like total just I I realize
there will be probably like very low IQ people who do watch this
eventually. Maybe if it's on YouTube or something, just so you
know, not saying Pixie has won this case, not saying Pixie is
winning this case. I actually have no idea. I'm not a lawyer,
okay? I I'm not saying that. I'm just saying that like Destiny
is clearly like openly lying about and trying to manipulate narrative
on his case publicly because he's very concerned about his reputation.
That's all. And I just point out when he is like clearly lying
and full of and it's funny. This is just content. I'm not giving
like legal advice or something. I'm I'm just sitting here covering
tweets and legal documents, okay? Because it's fun. Because I
enjoy doing it. Stop backtracking. Lol. You said the last time
his lawyers told him he's cooked. Uh, go ahead and send me the
I guess. Go ahead and send me the clip of me saying that. Yeah,
I I don't know. I You speak about these people with very low
IQs and they appear out of nowhere. It's incredible. Maximum
333. One of the lowest IQ fellows. Crazy. I found the specific
part in like the
the protective order that it's talking about. I don't know if
you want to look at it. Oh, do we want to look at it? Um, it's
up to you. Oh, maybe if you want to. Sure. for sure if you think
it's relevant. I'm just going to look at the other thing Pixie
posted here. So Destiny says, "Thank the court has has said they
need to file the unredacted versions under seal now." Uh Pixie's
council always planned to do this. They informed Destiny's council
of that. Destiny soyed the out about it in an
Maximum. I've never said that, but again, you you are just totally
minded. You are a disgusting mind DGer. It's okay. I can't even
really get angry at you guys anymore. You're like blind to most
of the world. We're all looking in at at your little circus.
We're all laughing at you. The rest of the world doesn't want
to deal with your predator in any way. It's gross. Okay. Deepack
was like, "You know what? This guy's actually gross. I don't
want my name attached to him." Dean Withers Parker. Okay, this
guy's gross. We don't want to be attached to him. That's his
reputation. That will be his reputation forever. He is a disgusting
perverted and he'll never get it back. He'll never get anything
back close to being like a normally a treated well human being.
Okay? He's just a total piece of We can hope this guy. This guy
just got raped and now he's raging. Good luck. I'm going to see
when the first mention of the what I just linked to is,
but I feel like it was before. It must have been before. Must
be a few weeks ago at least. Sure. So, we're looking at Pixie's
response to Destiny's tweet. Here it is. Uh, Destiny's claiming
his his only issue was not having access to the unredacted documents.
This is extremely interesting seeing that Destiny's attorneys
opposed the motion of filing under seal and wanted unredacted
versions filed before the seal was granted. In connection with
her motion for prelim preliminary injunction, plaintiff moves
to file under seal three anonymous declarations. Plaintiff's
motion should be denied for three reasons. Plaintiff failed to
meet and confer prior to filing her motion. Uh arguable, although
I don't think they gave uh Andrew Andy B a lot of time here.
Plaintiff refuses to identify the names of the declarance to
defendant Benell's council. and three the federal rule and statute
upon which plaintiff relies are not applicable so failed to provide
to destiny uh at 8:00 p.m. EDT roughly on Friday, May 2nd, 2025,
plaintiffs council emailed the undersign stating, "Pursuant to
local rule 7.1 A3, we are meeting and conferring on the following
motions. Motion to file under seal. Motion to do the page limits.
Sure, sure, sure, sure." Uh, supplementary Breler Declaration
A. Hold on. Lots of chats here real quick. Okay. All right. Never
mind. Nothing important. Supplemental Supplemental Breler Declaration
A. Emphasis added at 11:40 p.m. Oh, this is saying this is the
the notice for this. So, plaintiff filed declarations of redacted
form uh on May 3rd. Banell's council requested unredacted copies
of plaintiff's filing supplementary declaration exhibit B. Despite
repeated requests, plaintiff refused to uh I don't even know
did this I don't even know this necessarily happened here. Unredacted
versions not filed with the court but given to the opposing council
directly. I I believe Pixie's argument is essentially that without
the seal being granted, Destiny would have no reason to keep
those names private. Um, I believe he's rushed to beat the seal
in a couple different times. Okay. So, I believe, and correct
me if I'm wrong, I believe technically Pixie's team, it's same.
Oh, no, it's not same day, is it? I can't tell. The publishing
of the video is same is um after basically Destiny Destiny had
published on his channel a video that included Pixie's name in
it. after her team had filed the motion to protect her identity.
Right? So that has already happened and then Abby was uh the
Abby MC declaration that was filed under seal as well with her
screen name. Also, I don't know why people think this is the
case, but like you you can't possibly be dumb enough to think
that a screen name is equivalent to a full legal name, right?
That in an affidavit you have to put your full legal name on
the page and people are like trying to equate a a screen name
to that full legal name. This is completely nonsensical. Um that
is that is just very stupid. Anyway, um yeah, this is just completely
nonsensical. So, but with Abby as well, Destiny did the same
thing where Abby had filed the stuff under Seal and then he went
to his chat and people were asking about those those affidavit
filed under Seal and he goes, "Yeah, that Abby person is insane.
That's Darius's crazy ex. Yeah, she read my wife's diary. She
went read my wife's diary. Do you imagine how disgusting she
is? She violated my wife's privacy." Yeah, that's the wife who's
uh whose I sent to multiple people without her consent. Yeah,
but I'm really mad that the person violated her privacy. Oh my
god. Anyway, Kelly, did you send me the thing? Oh, you did. Okay.
Wants to go over this before we go over this. I've just been
going through the PDFs to see when this
uh when this was first mentioned by Pixie's team. But I I mean
I have the PDF where like Destiny's team are complaining about
it and their argument was against the rule 26 C1 of the federal
rules was that it's entirely misplaced
quotations as the authorities have no bearing on her motion to
file under seal. Rule 26 pertains to seeking a protective order
in connection with discovery. that basically their argument is
being sneaky and saying this should only apply to discovery when
they're fully aware that this rule has been used outside of discovery
and is done so moderately commonly at the court's discretion.
So, it was just like an attempt to block that they knew was going
to be a weak argument, which is odd that they didn't tell Destiny
that that would be a weak argument, but it's fine. I guess that's
why he thinks he knows better than everyone else, I guess. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. They're equivalent in terms of concealing identities,
though. No, no, no,
no. Obviously, obviously not. Obviously, we have this whole thing
of like when you're when you're doxing somebody, usually their
full legal name is like one of the first things in a dox, right?
But their screen names are everywhere. Why Why would we pretend
these things are equivalent? They're not equivalent. These people
are trying to avoid harassment on the internet. They they they're
trying to avoid harassment on the internet. not just to them,
but like to their families, right? That was one of Pixie's major
concerns was harassment towards her family. If you don't know
her full legal name, it's harder to harass her family objectively,
right? And wanting those not to be in documents that are going
to be reviewed by tons of people on the internet, that's just
that's totally appropriate. That's totally understandable. Anyway,
I also don't know. I don't so I understand where you're assuming
oh it looks bad if people are allowed to submit things without
um having fully redacted anything but I don't actually know if
that's like what kind of procedure that's against or if it really
is breaking any rules because if they choose to just strike it
instead of submitting say they didn't get the um they didn't
get the judges ruling in the favor would they really have definitely
done something wrong and if so what so I think the thing that
could be wrong is that Destiny could never fully articulate this.
It doesn't really make sense. He was saying that they were they
were openly lying and perjuring themselves, right? That's why
they wanted their identities like kept from him or something.
But that I understand I No, hang on. Hang on. I understand everything
around what you're saying, but we don't actually know if that
does break any rules, do we? We're just saying that maybe that
doesn't it's obviously not great for someone potentially, but
like who gives a like a lot of these things are like very uh
invasive in general to both sides. So, it's like um whatever.
But we we would need a lawyer to tell us if this actually breaks
a rule doing that cuz it might not be. He might just be throwing
a tantrum and it's like it's it's not like positive for him.
But like
sure, real quick answer this Duke of Luffy guy. If you don't
know, Aby's name was already included in the documents weeks
ago as a person of interest who might have information that Pixie's
team identified might have information by that screen name. So
again, I don't know how it works. I don't know if that screen
name had to be included or what was going on there. I I actually
don't know. There might be some rule there. I have no idea. I
really don't know. So yeah, I Where the is esports Batman? Cuz
I don't know how to look up rules that I'm not sure exist. And
like as far as I'm aware, like Destiny's Council didn't site
something specifically as a complaint. So I don't know cuz just
saying it could be sanctioned is meaningless. It's like well
what is being sanctioned and how and under what what legislation?
I don't Does the legislation exist? I don't know. Sure. Okay.
Anyway, we're uh good with that. We're going back to these tweets.
Destiny's attorneys were repeat told repeatedly they would have
access to the unredacted versions after the court ordered for
the names to be protected. Giving him access to the names before
the court could protect them would defeat the purpose of the
seal. The issue was never about him knowing whose accusers were.
It was about him knowing this information before the court could
protect them. Because when the motions were in that people wanted
protection but not yet granted, Destiny did identify these people
both times with Pixie with Abby, right? As far as I as far as
I can remember. If not, uh, he might have done the stream before
the motion to protect Pixie's identity went through, right? The
motion about filing his Jane Doe, but she did file his Jane Doe
originally. So, I mean, that's already indications. So, basically,
when when it's filed with the court, hey, we want to protect
this person's identity. Destiny seems to have a pension for going
on his stream and immediately identifying that person or going
to a public platform like DG Chat and immediately identifying
that person. And he has known Pixie for years and never once
called her by her first name. Not once. And then immediately
as soon as this starts immediately does he? He's a vindictive
little snake rat. Yeah, exactly. You guys don't know a lot, but
you're going to talk about it all. Yeah, exactly. Yep. Joe Rogan
style. Hey, I'm an idiot, but uh I'm going to go over these and
say what I think. Good luck. If you don't like it, leave. Good
luck. Okay, hold on. What are we looking for here? Destiny is
claiming Oh, whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Did we go through
this whole thing? This issue was never about him. No. Yeah. Yeah,
we went through this whole thing. Let's read the email that she
cites. Mr. Brenler, note that local rule 5.4b 4 B1 provides in
relevant part if prior to the issuance of a ruling on the motion
to file under seal the moving party elects or is required to
publicly file a pleading motion memorandum or other document
that attaches or reveals the content of the proposed seal material
then the moving party must redact that from public filing uh
redact from public filing all content that is subject to the
motion to file under seal plaintiff elected to attach the declarations
to the reply and file in a simultaneously oh yeah simultaneous
motion to file under seal. Yes. So they filed under seal and
they were under time pressure. Oh, the venet has no right to
receive the unredacted documents at this time. It would be highly
negligent if we were to provide to your client the unredacted
documents without the protection of their identities by the court
in light of your client's public statements over the weekend
maligning these declarants. This is Abby that they're referring
to explicitly. Right. Your client has also threatened physical
harm to other individuals that have spoken out against him and
in support of the plaintiff. Then this is me and me and Quimman
up in here again for JC and Queman. I kill them if I could. I
choke up their house and do it. I do want someone to kill Jtock
though or Lab or Mr. Girl or Queman. All those people can go
die. Yeah, exactly. Wow.
Who is the best odds of winning this case? I have no idea. I
would assume that without seeing any of the evidence so far,
I would assume that the defendant is, you know, usually advantaged
in every way in civil court, right? I I literally have no idea.
To me, like the actual bad behavior has already been admitted
to. Destiny signed something saying he did the things, right?
Okay. Anyway, moreover, you have the full unredacted substantive
content of the declarations. The only redacted portions are those
that would reveal the identities of these declarants. There can
be no legitimate urgency for you or your client to know these
witnesses legal identities that does not alter the facts or your
ability to defend your client in these proceedings. Yeah. So,
basically, Destiny's argument was, hey, there's no urgency. There's
no urgency, right? Sorry, Pixie's council's argument was there's
no urgency for you. And I don't see any argument against that.
There was no urgency here for him to gain those documents to
get access to that stuff, right? Like it could just go through
the court. They could wait for the judge to rule. That wasn't
a
And I I never heard him argue against that. That there's actually
like an urgent matter that he needed to deal with. The major
thing that gets them through like a summary judgement is the
Abby declaration, the ABMC declaration. And Destiny had already
served discovery notices to her before he started whining, before
he started picking his pants. He knew exactly who it was. I believe
Abby had already uh what had she done? She had already sent him
a letter of intent, right? Tune in to Destiny's stream to learn
how to disrespect women's consent. Oh my goodness. Can we go
get some some lessons in consent ignoring from him? I don't think
so. I think I'm good. You know, I Hey, for me personally, I just
like I like respecting consent. Okay, I know it's kind of not
quite in the DG wheelhouse, but it it is what it is. Okay. Also,
I looked into the local rule stuff and I I think I mostly understand
it. It's uh yeah, so it's talking about you should, you know,
submit the uh it fully redacted what have you, but it's like
uh it just basically says the judge most likely didn't care because
of the good cause. But prior to that where I read it's like plaintiff
redacted witness declarations under local rule 5.3b1 which allows
a party to file a motion to seal certain types of confidential
materials sensitive like sensitive personal information. They
did not immediately provide unredactive versions to defense council
because they're asking the judge to decide whether identities
should be sealed from both the public and the defense. At this
stage the plaintiff invoked a different subsection of the same
local rules 5.3 versus 5.4 for arguing the sealed motion process
justified temporarily withholding the identities until the court
ruled. So, it's a bit complicated, but it seems like ne they
didn't necessarily do anything wrong because it was temporary
and it was pretty temporary, right? We're talking about a matter
of a couple of weeks within the course of like I don't know how
long this is going to go on for. Is it like a year? I'm not I
can't remember what date they gave for next year. It's like pipelines.
It's not complicated. Okay, buddy. whatever. Well, there is a
little bit mostly because they gone back and forth. Like they
used a local rule and a federal rule and then they um used a
different part of the local rules and so like we can only assume
that the judge doesn't care because they authorized the ceiling
and that overrides the local rules. Like the local rules aren't
as important as the federal rules and I don't know what the federal
rules are in relation to that specific thing. I don't know. And
if it's any different. Okay. All right, but basically federal
rule trumps the local rule and judge said don't give a I feel
it's like the simple answer. Uh you guys need to separate Bixler's
argument from the remedy he was seeking. Bixler Bretler, why
do you keep saying Bixler? Uh yeah, exactly. Vigilance stream.
No, I think that's true. I think um he did have the they do have
the right they they do have the right. It's in the rules. Contemporaneously
uh with your motion, you should be sending to the opposition
like those lines, right? Sorry, those uh identities. Not the
identities, the unroadactic copies. Jesus. It'll be interesting
though if he sports Batman as right and like Destiny's council
deem him too much of a liability aka tantruming baby online that
they just uh don't want to tell him what the lead identities
are either. Honestly, they would be doing him a favor. It's like,
yeah, let's take the gun away from the psychotic baby before
he shoots himself or someone else. All of the court documents
are public. babysitting. He needs babysitting. Uh, good luck,
Destiny's council. Wow. Okay. Uh, all of the court documents
are public. I'm not sure why do is lying about them. I don't
Where did she lie? He would like that. Oh my god. No. I was such
an underrated comment. That was so good. Yeah. Please don't treat
Destiny like a baby. He's very, very into that. It's up. But
please don't. Oh my god. Oh, he's going to play that audio for
himself later. He's unlucky. Kelly, I think Destiny said he wants
to write the s summary judgement motion. Yeah, I do believe he
said he said that. Anyway, uh yeah, where's Vigilance Vigilance
Stream? I broadly agree with you that um that like the they they
should have to file contemporaneously and they'll have to address
that with the judge why they didn't do that, right? Anyway, so
he's saying Pixie lies or something. She hopes to have people
come in randomly to join motions. The the random thing is just
so funny. It's all random. It's all random. No, the the people
you want to was not random. I don't know that they do have to
answer it because when I looked it up, it like I just read it
out, but it says this simplicity overrides or pauses the usual
application of rule 5.4 F1A since the court has discretion to
approve deviations from local rules where good cause, which is
what the judge ruled in, good cause exists, like for example
safety or retaliation risks and harassment and that stuff. So,
I don't know that her council has to answer for anything. As
far as I can tell, like I think they did everything properly.
They do not need to address it for the judge. It is mood at this
point because the motion was granted. Yeah, exactly. So, they're
they're fine. It was lawful. It was okay. They can tantrum him
as much as they like on the other side. Although, I don't even
think his lawyers really fought it that hard. They submitted
like one paragraph about it. Okay. All right. Back. Hello. So
that Yeah. So it's like they don't have anything to answer for
just a call. It's already been approved. There's nothing. Uh
well, it's been approved, but obviously they still have complaints.
I'm assuming that at whatever magistrate hearing they're going
to raise those complaints, right? Hey, um the rules say that
these that underacted copies need to be filed with us and to
us contemporaneously, right? And that didn't happen. And the
jud that that objectively did not happen and there probably should
be a discussion about it, but okay. But apparently that just
doesn't matter because if like if good cause is given it overrides
that application of that local rule because the federal rule
is overrides this. Like it just literally doesn't matter. If
they complain about it, they'll be wasting their time because
the court ruled it there was good cause for it. So they're just
going to say there was good cause. Like what was he going to
argue? Kelly is right for the wrong reason. Oh yeah. So it's
just moot. It's moot. What is the wrong? I I'm guessing because
it's not actually like a matter of concern and that one Destiny's
already said, "Oh, I guess everything went how I wanted it to,"
which is weird, but uh I guess it's all fine. It would be a waste
of time, I think. Yeah. Sure, sure. Sure. No reason to continue
doing this. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Pensive goat. But apparently,
uh two of the people I know who actually have some amount of
legal understanding are saying that it's probably just going
to be moot. So, I I'll I'll give it to people. If it's moot,
it's moot. I think there's a there's a valid concern that like
people could just, you know, they could actually file things
that aren't true, right? They could put things out into the public
eye that harm Destiny's reputation and then uh remove their identities
and never face any penalties for that. That is a concern that
could be valid. It doesn't matter now because that concern can
never materialize. Right. But why would that be more important
when it's being submitted in this than it would be if they just
tweeted it or any other way? I don't um because it has damage
of reputation. It's an affidavit and it's being filed as legal
documents. There's like a weight to it. Um okay. But then the
person that's doing this would be having to would be willing
to like purge themselves, right? If they knowingly like submit
a bunch of false information. I don't know if Yeah. Fuve, but
they can address it when it comes up. I don't know what like
the punishments for these things are. Sure. Hey, uh by the way,
there would be no punishment to Pixie's case. It wouldn't affect
her case in any way. It would only be punishments on the lawyers.
Like the lawyers are not are not taking these affidavit in bad
faith and trying to present arguments they think are false. If
they were doing that and there was any indication they were doing
that from anywhere, they would get soed for that. It would be
crazy, right? It could material. It could, but it hasn't. So,
I think they're probably going to take their like they're not
it seems like most people are saying they're probably not going
to address it because it hasn't materialized. Okay. All right.
So, she hopes so. I'm going to read Destiny's comment here and
then I'm going to read the emails below. All the court documents
are public. I'm not sure why do is lying about them. Also, not
entirely sure why they're litigating this on Twitter, but okay.
Here is the email exchange do selectively quotes. The filings
are public. I'm not sure why they're litigating it on Twitter
to have me litigate it on Twitter. She hopes to have come in
randomly. She hopes to have people come in randomly to join motions,
make anonymous filings and accusations. And if the court rejects
the motion to seal these filings, withdrawing these names without
ever making them available to me, this is a violation of civil
procedure. What are we doing? Esports Batman said he didn't speak.
Oh, okay. All right. Uh, this is a violation of civil procedure
and obviously violative of my rights. The issue was never about
filings filing things under seal. It was about withholding names
from me, including a screenshot. So, he's made this like different
multiple times. And again, Pixie's like legal team never said
they were withholding the identities from him. I think what they
said was like once it's passed, we'll we'll hand them over to
you. Like we'll we'll file with the court. I think they said
and and Pixie's lawyer did say, "Hey, I don't see any urgency
for these to be handed to you, right? Like you can just wait."
And I agree with them that I don't think there's an urgency there.
I don't think there's any urgency. Well, is there an urgency?
It depends. But in a perfect world, the way that procedurally
this would work would be you'd file the motion first. The motion
would be granted or not granted and then you would file the yes
affidavit, right? Like that's the perfect order of operations
is is that that way that situation say this has to be the last
time that Pixie Council tries to go, "Oh, we were really pressed
for time." Like I think I think at this point now that it's twice
in the record, I feel like judges would have to be like, "Yeah,
you you're actually going to start forfeiting your ability to
like use exceptions for time pressures and stuff because you
you can't just leave it to the last minute and then say you have
a time pressure." But I will also say I've heard I've not seen
validated, but I've heard that they only had the affidavit signed
from Abby like shortly before they filed. That's I've heard that.
I don't know if that's true. If that were the case, then I mean
they probably were waiting on it and couldn't have done it earlier,
right? In cases like this though, surely people will be coming
forward as time goes on, right? So it's running there like the
lawyers are being like malicious somehow. I don't know how much.
Well, that was one of the questions that somebody asked me in
Discord earlier today because they wanted to know for instance,
does the seal apply to other witnesses beyond the scope of the
three that are mentioned? Is it, in other words, is the granting
of the seal a general grant or is it just a grant of the three
specific individuals at issue right now? And the way that the
judge's order said is it seems to be just for those three people,
which means if others come forward, you would have to potentially
make the same uh motion again for those additional individuals
who wanted to come forward. So, if like JTO wanted to throw out
an affidavit and remain uh anonymous, he would have to go through
that same process. So there there's going to be some give and
take as things drag on and preferably going forward they would
apply for the motion beforehand if they're doing it again. Okay.
Well, I mean, generally speaking, what so the the way that the
rule is structured is that it provides you the ability if you're
either under some time constraint or under some requirement filing
wise to contemporaneous or yeah, contemporaneously file the redacted
version with the motion because procedurally what would happen
is if the judge says there's no good cause for keeping this sealed,
then you would probably withdraw the documents or have them struck
from the record and then file the unredacted version. So really
in both cases you're not losing out on much as long as it isn't
surely that prejuditial to the parties involved. But given how
early we are before we even have like the end of discovery, you
have like another 6 months till the end of discovery. Uh it's
not going to be hugely pre prejuditial to make it wait or to
as you said is as people come forward come forward with stuff.
Now, at the end of this year, somebody comes in after, you know,
I think it's December 24th of this year,
um, and says, "Oh, I want to come forward." Then you might start
to have problems there. But as far as people coming in this early
on because the action wasn't filed until February or miday, so
just within the first 60 days, let's say, you know, okay, that's
going to be normally the discovery process as you're kind of
feeling out the uh parameters of the case. Are they in Discovery
now though? I thought they weren't there yet. I mean, technically
you are, but not formally. Um, the Discovery schedule has been
set and the deadline for the end of Discovery is at the end of
the year. Like I said, I think it's it's Christmas Eve this year.
That's part of the scheduling order. But as far as like the the
formal discovery quote unquote discovery period, yes, it hasn't
really technically started, but it kind of has because in any
case where you're filing, um, one of the things that you have
to do professionally as a good faith sign is you have to start
disclosing
um, named individuals who might be relevant to the case to get
people started. Um, this also allows you as a pre-trial matter
to start to discuss the scope of um, discovery and stuff like
that. And where you might have certain individuals testifying
or um, giving evidence for one specific instance and you want
to, you know, narrow the scope because the idea is generally
speaking, you want to narrow the scope of discovery. So, it's
the least amount of documentation, but it's also the least amount
of uh time and energy spent by the lawyers to then uh cut costs
and keep it as reasonable as possible. That makes sense. So,
what would this what is this area we're in now? We're not quite
in discovery, but kind of are. Is there a name for that? Not
really. You're you're just kind of in the pre-trial phase like
you know the we're still in motion. We're still in motion land.
So, there's going to be a lot of back and forth and that's about
Um, do you think it's weird that Destiny keeps calling this like
a surprise witness when in the initial disclosures from I believe
April 4th, uh, this person was like actually identified as somebody
who would have information. Uh, I don't know if I would say it's
a surprise witness. I maybe he was hoping Abby was going to be
his witness and that it's a surprise to him that, you know, she
decided to offer up her uh affidavit in support of Pixie. That
might be the surprise part of it. Who knows? Um but like
I feel like I've heard him like basically say that Aby's declaration
or her affidavit is essentially like a last minute 11th hour
hail Mary that's totally random and has nothing to do with the
case. I feel like I've heard it described in all of these ways.
I feel like it's like the opposite of that. It was like, "Hey,
these are people that we may have to question. We we who may
have more information and they're like, "Actually, we talked
to this person and here's the information they gave us." It seems
like it would just be like the normal course of what's going
on. But yeah, the the best I could offer is maybe he had um intention
of controlling the discovery from Abby because he knew about
Abby and therefore he could structure how he wanted to present
the information or how he wanted wanted to uh shape discovery
on her and her chats or her information that she has to offer
up. And it's a kind of a surprise for him because now it's no
longer, you know, somebody he gets to take the lead on, so to
speak. Uh, sure. Yeah. That seems possible. I just Yeah. I just
I the idea that it's uh again, we just see the word random come
up a lot. Things are just random. I don't I didn't see anything
here that seemed random to me. Seems all very like formed around
a very specific pattern. But I don't know. the the only thing
I can think of that he and I'm I'm spitballing here is that the
thought process is he felt that he was going to have a stronger
case and this uh the ABMC stuff which he thought would be probably
you know after any summary judgement motion assuming that it
went to more substantive discovery now has become before he's
had the opportunity to do a summary judgement motion which now
impacts his case
Um, and so he's seeing it as a Hail Mary to try and say, well,
after, you know, after the date the video was exchanged and therefore
now there is more of a substantive basis rather than um she having
to, you know, kind of scrge and prove on allegations as opposed
to unsubstantiated evidence. Yeah. Sure. Sure. I would say one
thing I do find very like possibly very um I don't know if it's
ironic but just the idea that he didn't want to file a motion
for summary judgement because it would have been expensive. He
basically said, "Why am I going to waste my money on that?" Right?
And the idea that they may not have had um any of the affidavit
that they propo that they put in the uh what do you call it?
The preliminary injunction motion. They might not have had those
affidavit. I think without those um they might not have survived
a motion for summary judgement. They they actually might not
have. And the idea that he was just cheap and didn't want to
file one, didn't want to pay Andy B to write up the paperwork,
right? I think that's um that could possibly be one of the funniest
things. A motion to dismiss. Sure, that's what I meant. A motion
to dismiss. Yeah. Or Yeah, a motion to dismiss. I don't know
why I said it that way. Yeah. But because I think, you know,
the only thing they had in the initial
uh the initial complaint was, "Oh, somebody's sister told me
that Destiny sent them the video or something, right?" Yeah.
That was the only thing that placed them within the Cardi. So,
I think if they had filed right away before Pixie had a chance
to go talk to people, that might have hit a deadline where they
they might have actually just dismissed it out of hand. Yep.
Right. because there wasn't enough well yeah they they wouldn't
have been able to dismiss the state totally but the fed the Cardi
claim would have been dismissed and then I think um subject jurisdiction
bar yeah you fall out of that so like they wouldn't have subject
matter jurisdiction because you wouldn't have the federal charge
anymore so because what's what's the state I think the state
maximum limit is something like uh I want to say it's $5,000
if I remember correctly but yeah that would significantly
even if he won that would be mere pittance Yeah. No, I I can
understand. But yeah, uh and then to Kelly's point about the
rules, the idea is that in most cases, judges have a lot of leeway
in the application of the rules or the deciding of what's important
and what's not. Um this is why for good cause always exists.
And you know, if the if there's an argument to be made and the
judge agrees with it and finds that it it makes sense generally
and it's within the bounds of the rules and the judge grants
it, then it's considered for good cause. Because the idea here
is
um the interest of justice, you know, not to prejudice the parties,
which as has been stated, Destiny is going to get or at least
his lawyers are going to get the unredacted
u declarance or the unredacted affidavits. So, they're going
to know who said what. And so, really, you're just hiding it
from the public at that point, which I think there's a legitimate
privacy interest there, especially cuz she's already been granted
the the right to file as Jane. Yeah. Okay. Okay. All right. Hopefully,
it stops him being a freak about other people as well. We'll
see. We'll see. We'll see. All right. So, somebody Wait, wait,
wait. Before you go, before you go, somebody wanted me to ask
you a specific question, and I do want to ask you the specific
question. Discuss the summary judgement standard given it has
been brought up. Do you know what the summary judgement standard
would be? Yeah. Basically, referred to summary judgement is saying
that the person doesn't even make a claim that is meeting the
legal
uh respects to what they're charging you under. So, it's without
a full trial when there's no genuine dispute about the facts.
Um, okay. And the idea is that you're just saying, "Hey, we both
agree to it. We both agree to the the the substance of the facts.
we just want you to make uh a judgment as to whether or not there's
a cause of action here or not. Um and then you you're you're
applying the facts to the law to see whether or not the the law
has been tripped or not or the violated. So what he's going to
argue probably under a summary judgement motion is I'm not disagreeing
with the facts. I'm disagreeing that the law was in effect or
that this cause of action exists. Uh and that's a matter of like
okay would this trip up under Cardi, right? If he was to sit
there and say, "I can 100% prove that there was no violation
of Cardi because the video was never sent before the time in
which Cardi became active." I'll agree to everything else as
far as sending the video. But, you know, unless we can say that
there's a uh instance of where it has been sent afterwards, there's
there's no genuine facts of dispute. Just see whether or not
I'm guilty under the law or liable under the law. Um, and you
go from there. Okay. All right. Oh, okay. I have one question.
What are you feeling about it? Just like a vibesbased argument
or a statement now that all of this stuff has happened. What
are you thinking will happen?
I want to see how the Yeah, I want to see how the uh the hearing
on the third shakes out. Okay. I could probably give you I could
probably give you a better feel for how things are going to work
um after the third. I don't know with the declarance if he's
going to survive summary judgement because the thing with summary
judgement is that you're saying that all of the main facts are
not in dispute, but there seems to be facts that that are in
dispute, right? And so what would it mean to not survive summary
judgement? It would mean that it would go further on in the trial
process, right? There's there's a motion to dismiss. Summary
summary judgement is basically where nobody's disagreeing on
the facts. They're disagreeing on whether or not the law applies
or not. Okay, that's that's the easiest way to like boil it down
for you. But where you have a situation like this where Pixie
saying, for instance, the video was sent after the Cardi date
and Destiny saying it wasn't sent before the Cardi date, that's
a issue of material fact that they both disagree on because that
determines whether or not the law applies or not. Now, if they
both agreed to the fact that the video was never sent before
the Cardi date, then you could go to summary judgement. But I
think that's a material fact. If anything, that issue
except the Abby thing, right? he would have to accept that Abby
Abby's thing is true. Otherwise, they'd need like um like proof
there or not? Like if it if it was if it was anything that um
basically if you had to apply like reasonability standard, would
you have to go to like a jury for that since it's a jury trial?
Right. So like let's say let's say Abby because I think Abby
in her affidavit, it it literally says she doesn't have links
to the videos, but she has like messages she saved of her talking
to other people about the videos she was sent, right? So, that'll
come down to like a jury making a call there to determine what
they think about some some I guess uh like subjective dispute,
right? I don't think there's that that would be a fact. So, he
would have to agree or Pixie would have to agree that it doesn't
apply, I guess, like for there to be no major facts in dispute,
right? Explicitly for the Cardi claim if they're using Aby's
affidavit to say, well, it falls within Cardi. Although, apparently
we have a case where um Cardi has been applied retroactively
for something published. We'll see how that works. I was going
to be that close. I was going to ask actually will it be likely
that they'll make the argument that Destiny making available
these links although they were not sent to Rose initially after
the Cardi date. They were like live for what years afterwards.
So I don't Is it worth them making that argument that they never
like sought to delete any of these things? So, this is the thing
that I'm most interested in the case about to see how courts
start to look at that. Um, yeah, I'm interested too to see whether
or not publishing only means sending if publishing because the
way the law is written, it says makes available. Now, what does
it mean to make something available? Does that mean because it's
publicly accessible in a Google Drive link? I don't know. So
that's my sole interest in the case is to see how uh the court
starts to look at stuff like this. Yeah. And um especially since
it was on like one of the one of them was on like a Google Drive
link and I know like um a lot of these people are older and the
Discord stuff probably confuses the crap out of them but surely
they understand the concept of being put on a Google Drive. So
yeah.
Uh he didn't send Pixie's video to Rose via Google Drive. Apparently
uh the Pixie video was provided to Abby via her affidavit via
Google Drive. That is what is said there. It's not publish. It
is um it is uh it's not deploy. Why do I always forget this?
I always forget the the word. It is disclose and transfer is
included in disclose. Make accessible is not um making public.
So, make accessible is the word you would want here to make accessible,
which is something that he Yeah. I wonder Yeah. I wonder if this
like uh how they rule on this will change those things. Like
maybe they'll change the way those things are written. It'll
be really interesting to see if this is kind of cool to see when
like cases like influence a law in the future.
Yeah. And uh I know with the law that they just signed today,
I think it was
um it's even more tougher than Cardi and I believe it um doesn't
act retroactively, but it would apply to
um more broadly to stuff including things like um AI and stuff
like that. So that's going to be super interesting, too. Wow,
that is interesting. Called the Take It Down Act and it was I
believe it was just signed. Oh, it was yesterday it was signed.
Okay. Um, but it was it Yeah, it's basically anyone under the
law who distributes in images of someone without their consent
faces federal criminal penalties. The law mandates that social
media companies must promptly remove such content when alerted
and it empowers the FTC to enforce it. Um, so it's going to be
super interesting to see how that works now because now people
can start to force sites like Kiwi Farms to take it down. Um,
so I don't know if they can because it's not hosted in America.
That's usually how these places get around is by not being but
I mean the the person Yeah. But if they do any banking,
right? Yeah. But the problem is all these people eventually use
American banks to do their or they use companies uh hosting companies
that do business in America and so then you have jurisdiction.
Blessings. Hello. Hello. How's it going? Hello. Hello. As well.
Can somebody inform me what Abby did in the context of this lawsuit?
I never figured it out. Uh, sure. She signed an not signed. Well,
no, she did sign. Uh, she signed an affidavit under penalty of
perjury that Destiny sent the Pixie video to her in like uh I
don't know, some sometime in 2023. So, basically, um, Pixie had
evidence that Destiny sent the video to Rose, this Rose person
in 2022. In April of 2022, the law went into effect in October
of 2022. And then basically Destiny could probably actually ask
for the federal charge to be dismissed if there's no evidence
of him sending the Pixie video in 2023. He actually signed an
affidavit as well that said that he'd never sent it after the
2022 date. Like and he said it in no uncertain terms and I've
never done that ever. Right. I absolutely have not done that.
And he signed an affidavit. Yeah. So that's basically like uh
I will testify to this fact in court if you if required. Can
he be tried for some form of perjury for if that's under penalty
of perjury? Yes. Same with Aby's.
Okay. So, Abby basically literally one of them has to be violating.
Well, one of them I mean they could they could be misremembering
or something, right? Technically. Oh, is that you can make an
appeal of misremembering and then not Well, usually for a lot
of these other statements in his affidavit, he said to the best
of my knowledge, but for this one, he did not say that. Uh although
he said at the beginning of the paragraph, so I'm not sure how
that applies. We'll see. We'll see how they interpret it. In
any case, um if Pixie couldn't prove that the video was sent
after uh October 2022, there's a chance that her federal claim
would be dismissed. I'm going to look at a case after this where
apparently that's um not happened. But there's a chance her federal
CA federal charge could be dismissed and then they're in federal
court. So the argument Destiny's team was making was if there's
no federal charge, we shouldn't be in federal court. you should
dismiss all the charges and they can file the refile the state
charges.
Yeah. So, basically Aby's testimony now makes it so that probably
there won't be just like a summary judgement or a motion to dismiss
that would be
Yeah. Because with summary judgement, the idea is that you have
to show through the evidence that has been presented to the court
that there is either no claim at issue or that it
um doesn't have the facts can't show that claim with the facts
at evidence. So, and so you guys don't believe it's likely that
either of those things will occur because of Aby's presence inside
of this lawsuit? I I mean I don't know. I I like I don't know,
but it it basically the claim from before was oh, how Destiny
was trying to get like this um this motion dismissed and the
broader case probably dismissed was he was saying there's no
subject matter jurisdiction for this court because the federal
charge is not valid. So basically Aby's declaration, her affidavit
makes it so that that is not the case anymore. Yeah. Because
before that there's a lack of evidence on Pixie's part to show
that the video was circulated after the Cardi date. So yeah,
Destiny would argue, hey, with all the facts given before us,
there's not enough evidence to support even in taking things
in her favor, which when you do file for summary judgement as
the moving party, the party that's filing for uh summary judgement,
the facts are taken in the best light to the non-moving party.
So, if Destiny were to file for summary judgement, you'd look
at the facts most as they would be most favorable to Pixie, but
you'd still have to show that there's a potential uh distribution
of that video after set date. And so, what he would likely argue
is say, "Hey, look, even with everything that Pixie is saying,
even taking her at her word and that she could produce that evidence,
there's nothing to suggest that there was a video sent after
the uh Cardi enactment date. Therefore, there's no real issue
here. let's let's go ahead and just rule on it. Um but now with
Aby's stuff, it comes into contention as to whether or not there
was a video that was sent after the card date and then now you
still have to get to the bottom of that. Yeah. Um any other new
developments? I saw they were fighting on Twitter, which I don't
know how their lawyers are allow that, but I saw them fighting
Twitter. On Pixie's side, what I've said repeatedly is probably
her lawyers are probably saying like this is what you can say
because they need to get paid and she needs to fund raise, right?
I don't know why on Destiny's side with all the money in the
world he would do this, but um on Pixie's side with her needing
to like literally fund raise. I believe that's how she started
her whole thing was like her first post was like he vindictive
because he needed to call her a liar on Twitter desperately.
her first first post was like court update ends with please please
donate please donate and then basically I think Destiny quoted
her thing and like started talking and so she responded uh which
again I assume is because she wants to actually get people's
eyes on it and you know Destiny is a super costic person if you
you know put yourself out there a little bit and he's attacking
you I feel like a lot of people will go oh I forgot how big an
this guy was you know what I will give a little money I think
that's the hope
See, we need to organize the sun money drop. Yeah, she needs
a son's community to do one of those fundraisers. You need to
organize some kind of a fundraiser like maybe a group effort
or something if you got a lot of people involved. I don't know.
Nicole have to stop saying Hassan is bad every 5 minutes to get
Hassan up. I It's obviously a whole bit, Kelly. What are you
talking about? Also, you think the bit is going to be appealing?
Also, I'm friends with Queenman, who's Hassan's new best friend.
So, hey, you know what? How did that happen? He's like, "Oh,
this guy is running a fundraiser for this pixie first and let's
look at it's his dream." And it's just equals thank bad like
20 times in a row. Enemy of my enemy.
Never mind. I'm just going to close this tab. Yeah. So, these
really, what are you going to bring on Pisco? I I I want to hear
what he has to say about the case. About this? Yeah. Is definitely
not talking about this. Oh, Assan is bad. Asana is bad. As Hold
on, I'll mute for you guys so I can just do this to my own is
bad. Asan is bad. I was gonna say, look at how cute these penguins
are. I don't know who made them, but they're very cute emotes.
That would be Top Bronson. Yeah, Top Bronson makes the the penguins.
He could probably make a penguin at some point. He might be working
on Really Penguin. I I never
Really penguin would be much appreciated. Yeah, a really damn.
Anyway, I I feel like I totally understand why Pixie's arguing
on Twitter. I I don't think it's like good for her mental health,
but at some point I also assume that like, you know, if she were
to have to ask people to like mortgage something to fund her
her case until she can either get her legal fees recovered or
I don't know, just get I I assume that's stressful, too. So,
probably those two things, you just be like, "Hey, I got to I
got to do this one." All right, that's fine. Yeah. I got to I
got to fund raise. Okay. I don't want to My parents shouldn't
have to mortgage their house. I want to fund raise. Yeah. So
24 hours. He's a lawyer. Sure, sure. Sure. 24-hour stream. I
wish I had the fundraising capability.
I do not get Queman in. Listen, me and Que will do a 24-hour
um Drew Pablo, all these like random political grifters who are
in the like vaguely lib like center lib space who really have
no principles whatsoever. We could we could do a stream on those
guys. Those guys that'd be easy.
Didn't you hear though? bad empanada is gonna come to Twitch.
Oh man, I dude Yeah, I'm so I'm so over the um the what do you
call it? Like the bad empist listen, I understand he's bad, but
I'm so over people who will like associate with Destiny being
like bad empanadas over the line. That's crazy. Hassan, you're
complete piece of [__] It's like they're the same
person. Except that somehow somehow Bad Empanada's beard is less
bad. He might bad empanada has the second worst beard on the
entire internet, but somehow it's less bad than Destiny's. It's
crazy. Listen, Destiny's support for Israel is so great, it's
started to manifest on his body. Just Just let it happen. Are
you sure it's Israel or is it just the Gaza Strip? Not sure which
one yet. I think it's the greater Israel. He would be skinnier
if it was the Gaza Strip, surely. Yeah. Well, Jesus Christ, Kelly.
Jesus Christ. All right. Uh, what are we doing here? We're looking
at Oh, uh, we're going to keep going back and forth on the Twitters.
Okay, we looked at Destiny's response to this, which was right
here. Pixie responds and says, "I have not lied about anything.
The emails you have posted further illustrate my point. I suggest
you reread the objection your legal council filed. Your legal
team asked to file unredacted versions before the seal was granted
or strike them from the record. If this was truly a civil rights
problem, why even suggest withdrawing/ striking from the record?
Wouldn't the demand only be to know the of the identities?" That's
to me. So Destiny's argument was they're lying, they're perjuring
themselves, and they're hiding their identities from me. If he
believes that strongly, why wouldn't he just not oppose the motion
and let them be filed so he would get the unredacted copies and
could subpoena them? Wouldn't you want wouldn't that be the much
better legal strategy to just go like, "Oh yeah, I'm definitely
not opposing this. Get those people in here, right? Am I missing
something logically there?" And didn't he have like uh a point
where he was sitting there just saying it even for doing this
that they should be sanctioned? Uh yes. Okay. Yeah. He said that
he said they should be sanctioned. Absolutely. Yeah. Okay. Lu
says, "Okay, that's Wait, why is that?" If you're positive that
the other side is perjuring themselves, why would you let them
get away with withdrawing those? Why wouldn't you just say, "Yeah,
I'm actually not going to oppose this. I'm going to let that
be filed because I know that those people are perjuring themselves."
Yeah, Raj, I actually was totally wrong on that. Why would you
not defend yourself? Hold on. He's not not defending himself.
He's not opposing their ability to be filed under seal. Those
are those are not the same thing. What do you mean not defending
yourself? I How is that not defending yourself? There's there's
there's a difference between filing something under seal or not
making it public on the record, but still having access to it.
You see a lot of times this become an issue when it comes to
things like um finances or other personal information as it relates
to divorce cases or child custody cases. Like obviously there's
a lot of information particularly to children that isn't uh on
the record or that gets sealed because it involves a child. That
doesn't mean that they don't have access to it as far as the
opposing parties are concerned. It just means that the public
doesn't have access to that which is the exact purpose of this
seal. Right? It's to prevent people uh from accessing pacer and
just like or court listener or whatever and then just seeing
the unredacted versions of this and then using it to harass people.
That's Oh, that reminds me. Okay, so me and Jessica were talking
about this before you came on, I think. And I said we don't know
because me and Jess don't know. Is there like some specific rule
that is being broken by like the council by submitting redacted
only in name but submitting the rest of the document like is
that like because the the redaction request even in the rule
sits there and says that any information that you want to be
redacted including witness's name if I remember so he's literally
been throwing a tantrum over nothing because yeah any information
you wish to have redacted right you could have names redacted.
You could have specific
um uh intimate details redacted if you're talking about like
a sexual assault case or something like that. Um there's a number.
It's not just limited to like the entirety of the information.
And in fact, the rules generally speaking are going to favor
a lesser amount of redaction than a larger amount of redaction.
Right. Oh, okay. Really interesting. and redacting only for what
you need to have redacted as opposed to just redacting everything.
Um oh wow there you go. So he was just throwing a tantrum over
nothing cuz he didn't like it cuz it's not fair. Okay. So from
my understanding esports Batman uh from my understanding seal
uh the rules were contemporaneously you file unredacted copies
with the opposing council. You you send unredacted copies to
the opposing council. Yes. Yes. Yes. You do. And they didn't
do that. So, that seems to be the thing he was upset about. One
of many things he was upset about. Yeah, you can be upset about
that, but if they've already promised it to you, then let them
not send it to you and then make a complaint to them in writing
regards to that. And then if they still don't send it to you
even after the judge grants it, then you can make your complaint,
right? Like this is one of those things by you go back to the
hearing which the judge had to begin with where he was admonishing
both sides to sit there and say you have to work this out. So
to say hey we're going to file these affidavits we're going to
also file them under seal once the seal has been granted we're
going to go ahead and give them to you
know
urgency isn't of the matter sick monkey chamber. Thank you for
the and I agree with that. So really, it just becomes a matter
and I could see them being upset. For instance, if the court
had taken, let's say, two months to get around to granting the
seal, right? Sure. Okay. Then you can have a more substantive
conversation. But what was it like a week, if that? Yeah, it
was pretty fast. It wasn't that long. Um, it might be more than
that, though. Uh, it could be closer to three. Let me check.
I thought May 3rd the first time they filed these affidavit.
I thought May 3rd was the date they filed these sealed affidavit.
Yeah. So May third. Yeah. Two and a half weeks basically. Yeah.
Okay. Two weeks. And keep in mind we're talking business days
too. So really in reality it wasn't even it was it was just over
two weeks. Yeah. Uh I assume that also if you if you really thought
so his his original argument was they're perjuring themselves.
They're just lying. And then if this gets denied, if we actually
deny the motion's denied, they get to pull these back without
me being able to question those people. I assume that if he wanted
to serve discovery to those people, he would put that in some
kind of motion before a judge or maybe even in the hearing here
and say, "I need those identities to question those people because
I think these affidavit were filed in bad faith." Right. Well,
not just that, but you could always sit there and say, "I'm still
interested in what they had to say, and I still want to question
them." or there there especially when he already dis served discovery
on Abby anyways to sit there and say like I'm interested in what
you have to say. So yeah, there's always that opportunity as
well. And again, that's a discussion that you can have if you
truly think that they were filing it in bad faith. You could
bring that up with the judge. Yeah, which I think he he should,
right? Like he he is claiming that uh he has claimed multiple
times publicly that he knows that people are perjuring themselves.
I think he absolutely should be bringing this up with the judge.
In fact, I think you should take him as like a total liar in
public if he doesn't do so. If that's not brought before the
judge like, "Hey, we think that these people were compelled to
give false testimony." I don't know why he wouldn't be saying
that. He's perfectly happy to say it publicly. Oppose them and
ask them about that, right? Like that's the purpose of depositions,
to be able to have that discovery and be able to ask those questions
or interrogatories, which are just written versions of a deposition,
right? They're questions that you write down and then they provide
written answers and in response. But again, you're six, seven
months out from the end of discovery and the court's turning
around in two weeks pretty much on the day to respond to a motion
to seal. That's pretty good. And in those two weeks, are you
really going to be able to do you really need those names in
those two weeks? I mean, you can argue you can you can make the
argument, but and maybe the judge will have something to say
about that. Maybe he will admonish them to sit there and say,
"Hey, this was not appropriate. You shouldn't have been doing
this. You should have provided them contemporaneously." But does
it can I make the argument that it truly prejudices Destiny's
ability to mount a defense? No. I I I I personally don't see
it that way. But that's again that's my my view of things. And
if I would hope that by now that they have served the unredacted
copies to Destiny's Council, I don't see why there shouldn't
be. Well, I think they I think they filed them with the court
like so through Pacer I believe council should be able to access
the documents. Yeah. So yeah, what's the issue? Yeah, I don't
know. That's that was my whole point. So in the emails, uh Pixie's
council say I don't see the urgency for like you to receive these
copies ahead of us filing them with the court. And I think that's
totally reasonable, right? There's just not there's not real
urgency here. And in reminder again, the way that the rule is
structured in a perfect world, you would wait until the motion
is granted before you file anything to begin with. Why you doing
this to me? Right? You would file a motion saying, "Hey, we have
these declarants. We have under affidavit.
Um, we would like to redact their names. Here's the reasons why
the court grants it." And then you would file the redacted things
with the court giving the order to seal. council would then be
served contemporaneously
with either through pacer or actual service
black and you go about the case as you would normally would from
there. Yep. In which case you would have to wait that long anyways
in which case those two weeks would have gone by regardless without
you having access to them. So there's that. But
yeah, I just I don't I again there just wasn't any real urgency
there. He was like proposing a hypothetical that really didn't
affect him uh in like any way. So I I just don't get it. Like
basically the only person he didn't know was somebody whose affidavit
by his own by his own standard had nothing to do with the case.
So he wouldn't even depose it. He like didn't care, right? It's
like literally he's just going to argue that it's irrelevant.
Yeah. So like I I he was basically like conjuring a scenario
that could feasibly hurt somebody at some time and trying to
get his community like riled up about it and angry in in his
uh in his favor. But someone asked if could you argue that having
to spend money in the interim creates urgency? No, not really
because the lawyers would only be able to bill for the work that
they can actually do. Why are you doing this to me? So if there's
no work to be done there, it's not like the way that the legal
profession works is you bill in literally increments or by ten
of an hour by drinking obvious amount of alcohol working on a
particular case. You don't build to the client. So if there's
no work to be done on that, thank you very much. That's crazy.
Maybe consider not drinking running the clock to run the clock.
Good luck. Now, what you could argue in the best case scenario
is that the urgencies necessary in order to get everything together
for a timely service of a uh summary judgement motion or a motion
to dismiss
on the basis of uh not wasting the court's time, but I don't
think you're going to necessarily get that one either on, you
know, on a week or two difference. You better make up your mind.
Sure. All right. Okay. Let's see here. Any other questions? I'm
looking I wasn't looking at Twitch chat. Just hold on. Let me
No, we're good. We're good. All right. Um, what else was there?
I don't think there's necessarily anything else. You chilling.
What is the Hello. Where is the sun? Oh, did I muted my mic for
you guys? I muted my mic for you guys. Whoops. That's my bad.
Uh, I was talking to chat though. Chilling when esports was talking.
No, I said thank you to Toya who donated while he was talking.
I didn't want to cut him off, so I just let the dono play while
he was talking, unfortunately. All right, I'm gonna hop out.
I've yapped enough. Have fun. Okay, we'll talk to you later.
Thank you. See you. Bye. Bye. Okay. Okay. Does it feel good,
Kelly? It feels good. Yeah, cuz I was right. Everyone's been
seething at me because I screenshot chat GPT.
Okay. Uh, hold on. I'm I'm setting up uh my Really Penguin right
now. We got a Really Penguin going. He's on the phone, but listen.
When he comes back, there will be a relli penguin, I believe.
Yes. Uh, it is very appropriate also, which is very interesting.
Look at that. Look at the penguin with the glasses. Look at him.
Look at him. Look at him. Oh my god. Wait, I learned the name
of this penguin the other day. Uh, a king penguin. A really funny
name. A macaroni penguin. A macaroni penguin. Yes. Macaroni.
Macaroni. All right, cool. Where were we? I was reading these
messages. I have not lied about anything. The emails you have
posted further illustrate my point. I suggest you reread your
objection. Your legal council filed. Your legal team asked to
file unredacted versions before the seal was granted or strike
them from the record. If this is truly civil rights problem,
why even suggest withdrawing striking from the record? Wouldn't
the demand only be uh to know the know of the identities? So
strike strike them from the record if they remain private. Further,
plaintiff's reliance on rule 26 C1 of the federal rules of civil
procedure and 15 USC 6851 is entirely misplaced. So those authorities
have no bearing on her motion to file under seal. Rule 26 pertains
to seeking a protective order in connection with discovery. Apparently
Kelly said, you know, chat GBT told her that there are ways this
has been used in discovery or not discovery um in terms of motions.
So all right, give me civil procedure 26 C1. Kelly also read
the federal rules for the specific section. The code section
provides that the court may grant injunctive relief maintaining
the confidentiality of a plaintiff using a pseudonym 15 USC 6851B
3B. Neither is applicable here. Okay. Well, no. The answer is
CHP is a tool. So, it can only be as good as the things you input
into it. If you spur it, also going to give you spur. Well, oh,
no, no. Also, if you just literally if you put something into
it and it gives you an answer and you just double check the answer
against the actual like rules of civil procedure. Yes, of course.
That's pretty easy. Pretty easy. But what I will say is I do
pay for the subscription model which is the better one, but also
I input the PDFs of the court filings and it actually predicted
which rule Pixie's team would be using before I put in the PDF
that had that rule in it. So it correctly predicted it and then
it explained it to me too, which is quite good. Oh, cool. I found
it pretty useful for legal stuff, but obviously you have to go
through and read and I I don't ever or I try not to use it unless
I'm actually going to go through and um make sure that when I
read the rules themselves, they're like working as I expect or
they they or function as if you're a [__] you're
you're going to get answers and also not be able to process any
of the information. So again, it's just a tool, right? You should
always double check any information that's given to you. But
that's the whole point of anything, isn't it? You double check
stuff. Things can be wrong in books. They can be wrong online.
It's obviously not just unique to JPT. Oh, okay. Yeah. Exactly.
Okay. Uh, so Destiny continues. The demand is made because your
lawyers were suggesting they can file secret declarance to the
court to support their motions and then simply withdraw them
if the court denies their motion to seal without ever making
them known to us. You have no idea what you're talking about.
I don't know why you're tweeting about this. um this could possibly
be a problem, but it literally didn't happen. And Destiny is
trying to blow it up into like a an urgent issue instead of just
being like, "Oh, yeah, the the court will provide me the identities
anyway," which definitely would have just happened. And now it's
a mood issue entirely. So, I don't know why I don't know why
he actually feels the need to try to make it urgent. Sorry. I
do know why. It's because he's desperate to shape narratives
and there are a lot of people who are desperate to have his [__]
dribbled in their mouth in terms of feeding getting fed narratives
from him. So, like, uh, this guy's in a lot of the replies. Where's
the other guy? The Conro, the the Ben Shapiro guy. That guy is
just the most. Jesus. I need to go through these tweets and preemptively
block these people. What? Absolute mouth breathing spurs. Oh,
he's with the [__] analogies. Well, if it's the only
thing Destiny can think about and we're trying to think like
a predator would think, unfortunately, this is where we have
to go. Split kitty lit. Sometimes when you stare into the abyss,
the abyss stares back and it's fairly disgusting. I just I suggest
you look at the stream. I'm a penguin. Yeah, it's got eyebrows.
I look like the from Surfs Up. Yeah, exactly. Macaroni penguin.
It's a macaroni penguin. Is that what it's called? Yeah, I love
I love macaroni. Got glasses. We're just um I don't know if you
watched any of Destiny's coverage of this, but he basically suggested
multiple times that uh One second. Glad that thanks for the notification
uh the the reminder. But so he claimed multiple times that he
believes Pixie's lawyers are getting people to perjure themselves
or possibly I'm getting people to perjure themselves for this
case. It's fairly insane, but that's why that's why he wants
sanctions for Pixie lawyers because they've they violated all
the rules apparently and also they're like supporting people
perjuring themselves to keep the case going. So he wants them
to be sanctioned. I would love to see, you know, going forward
if they will be sanctioned. supporting people perjuring themselves.
How? Uh, I don't know. He seems to have some theory here for
No, he didn't really elaborate. Oh, no. Right. Yeah, it's uh
Yeah, it's a little crazy. I don't I don't know what it means.
I wish I did. Uh, hold on. I need to Yeah, that that would be
uh informative, I guess.
If they are sanction No, Ro, that was um I thought things were
a certain way, but they're not really that way. Listen, listen.
I had a personal reason for not wanting to cover it, but actually
that personal reason was totally wrong and I thought about it
for a little bit more than one second, and that was just really
stupid on my part. So, pretend it didn't happen.
What didn't happen? Oh, I said I wasn't going to cover Destiny
stuff as much anymore, but then I had to listen to him like totally
lie about a whole bunch of things and I was like, "Oh, uh, no."
Uh, it's just so frustrating when I have to listen to this guy
like lie about random [__] It's very bothersome.
I get very irritated. Very, very irritated. I don't I actually
don't know if they'll be sanctioned. They could be sanctioned
for not following the rules of civil procedure for not providing
contemporaneous copies to opposing council. Possible. It seems
very unlikely now because of all the reasons that I've said like
three times which seems very skeptical of and the fact esports
Batman said the same thing. And also say he didn't say it wasn't
a problem. He didn't say it wasn't a problem. He just said it
was unlikely. It could still be. No, but he for the same reasons
that like the federal rule trumps the stupid local rule. There's
no reason to care anymore about it. It's kind of dumb. Yeah.
Here, I turned the shading off for the avatars then. Basically,
uh, yes. Hold on. We'll do that. Why do I have a lazy eye? There
it is. Uh, cuz you're like kind of like a nerd, I think. Oh,
no. The the eye is kind of lazy, actually. I think it's basically
taking your old avatar and it uses like some AI thing to like
switch it over to a different avatar. So, it's like supposed
to look like your old one as well. And there's something about
the eyes there that got messed up with. I don't know. I don't
know, man. Do I have a lazy eye in real life? I don't believe
so. Is this Is this Is this foreshadowing real life? I don't
I don't believe so. Not that I know of. Not that I know. Jesus.
Uh, this is so annoying. I can't go I can't like view Destiny's
quote tweets because he's me blocked. He's not going to block
Pixie. Why does he have me blocked? That's [__] me
as well. Little [__]
How have you been rally? Are you back in Arizona now? I think
was it? I am. And it's actually very nice. I like being in Arizona.
I bet away from Indeed. We have controlled chaos over here. I
like it. Is there a reason why you like Arizona specifically?
Do you have like family and stuff there?
No. I ain't got no family. Uh but it's uh it's just hot and I
like the heat a lot. A dry heat. um unlike dog Austin and uh
it's uh it's just like consistent weather. I like it. And also
there's just not as much bugs. I feel like Austin there's a ton
of bugs. Here there's just not as much. Honestly kind of a bugs
can't humidity. I'm guessing they just dry out all the time.
Oh yeah, he blocked Jacob's private Instagram despite never having
like interacted with him on like his Instagram just to block
him. is so funny. Oh, he's such a petty freak. Uh, yeah. So,
I think we've covered all the tweets. I don't know if there's
I feel like there's probably other like if we go and look at
just Pixie's replies, I'm guessing would be ridiculous. Uh, let's
see here. I know his drawing and striking are not the same, but
the consequence would be effectively the same. He would still
not get the names in the alternative scenario his legal team
suggested. What Destiny says he's okay with versus what his lawyers
are filed uh are two very different things. Oh, cool. That his
sanction doesn't matter. Destiny's team said give the names under
seal or strike the declarations. No, they said file them unredacted
before they're under seal. That's what they said. It's literally
in the circled thing. For the fourgoing reasons, Banell requests
the court deny plaintiff's motion to file under seal and order
the plaintiff to file unredacted versions of the declarations
or strike them from the record. That's what it says here. Why
is this person just lying? That person was just lying. That guy
is just a liar. This guy just doesn't understand. He's just You
know what? I'm going to
This guy This guy is too young to be allowed to interact with
me. What? spending even like two seconds like reading into things
themselves is just very funny. Dumb people interacting with you
should be be easy interactions.
No, all DJers are far too cowardly to come and like argue any
of these things ever. Very sad. Well, did you see the very violent
person was trying to do with me on Twitter? Trying to do violent
very violent. Oh, is that a username? Low IQ. Yeah, it's a username.
Yes. Damn. Uh, what were they trying to do, Kelly? trying to
make it. I mean, I just like cue the argument. Very violet is
one of the biggest idiots I've ever seen. Yeah. Um I felt bad
telling them like before uh Desi published his little thing.
It's like it's just going to try to like muddy the waters and
call Pixie a You understand that, right? It's going to work on
you. By the way, I literally told them it's going to work on
you. You are not strong enough to like resist going back there.
You are too lonely in real life. You don't have anything going
on. You will just go back to DG. And they're like, "No, I won't."
And then they're like, "Oh, implied consent. Oh, that's a real
thing. Droni, thank you for the 13 months. Appreciate it, buddy.
Hold on. Okay. Kelly was a doctor. Now she's a lawyer. God, you
are so dumb. You please support your claim with evidence critiquing
the argument itself. Be far more constructive than resorting
to personal insults. Dr. Kelly, this guy, one of the few in my
There was a couple of people actually in my Twitter today who
weren't, so that's nice. Normally, it's like pure, but there
were a few people like demanding other people like actually engage
with stuff, which is good. Yeah. Uh, first the timeline is important.
Plaintiff's lawyers suggested that they didn't have to send his
lawyers the names of all the pe people at all. Uh, defendants
lawyers made these weak arguments, but it was in response to
the prior suggestion of a unilateral break in procedure. Oh,
unilaterally redacting as if that's not a thing was really funny,
too. That is absolutely a thing. You could say, "Hey, we have
to file under seal. Also, we're redacting the things until the
motion to seal is ruled on." That's actually in the rules. So,
this is kind of dumb. But no, they didn't. Uh, at no point did
they state that the defendants's council would never receive
the names, just that they would not share unredacted versions
till the court ruled on the ceiling request. Do you agree they
were weak? Okay. They should have shared the unredacted versions
with council and redacted it publicly. Uh, they so the rules
say they should, but there are exemptions there like the sorry
if there was no other considerations, the rules would say yes,
but there are other considerations. And do you know what the
punctuation marks around weekly imply? These law defendants lawyers
made these weak arguments, but it was in response to the prior
suggestion of unilateral. Okay, whatever. Uh, the use I Yeah,
whatever. This is uh not an entertaining argument, Kelly. The
heck. The use of 26 C is quite literally to request exception
in the first place. The court granted the request, meaning the
process was unlawful. This is like a lawful. There are slightly
different things here going on, Kelly, right? 26 C is the reason
I believe they get the motion passed, but not the reason that
they don't file um that they don't give the unredacted copies
to the other the other party. So they're like it's about the
protective orders and the things relating to those. Yes. But
that's what this conversation was about if you actually bother
to read the first tweet. Okay. Calm down. You didn't bother to
read the first tweet. What was the first tweet? This one. Council
made a weak argument. Okay. This one. Dusty's council made a
weak argument that you couldn't invoke rule 261 and the judge
disagreed and ruled in your favor. We can assume the reason why
is partly due to his poor behavior. The kind of ego he has to
assume he knows more than you do is honestly quite funny. Yes,
I was talking about that.
So if somebody engages me in this thread, I'm going to that's
what I'm going to be talking about. And this is like the federal
rule, not the local rule, which is more important. So don't care.
Dr. Kelly JD, let's go. While the location of rule 26 is in the
discovery section gives surface plausibility to their claim,
courts have long interpreted 26 more broadly when parties are
seeking to protect sensitive witness identities, explicit or
highly personal information, threats of harassment or retaliation.
It's especially common to invoke rule 26 C, even outside of formal
discovery, such as when attaching declarations to motions when
dealing with synonymous plaintiffs or third party witnesses during
early injunctive relief proceedings. Oh, it's like all of those.
Crazy. Cool. Yeah. No. Wow. That's how you use properly. And
again, this would be why you can redact the things, but I don't
think this is necessarily why you wouldn't provide unredacted
copies contemporaneously. I think that's a separate argument,
but it's it's fine. I'm not spec talking about that specifically,
am I? Just talking about what I'm talking about. What are you
talking about, Kelly? The people are spuring at me and arguing
about some other things, but I'm always going to be referring
to what my point was originally, and they can lump it off. Off
All right. Uh, so Oh, hold on. We got a fixed eye here. Hold
on. Wait. Top Bronson, with the fixed eye, does it not blink
anymore? I don't see this guy blinking. I like blinking with
the lazy eye. Oh, no. It does blink. Never mind. Hold on. I'm
fixing Rey's lazy eye. Don't make fun of my lazy eye, man. I'm
sensitive. Fix this lazy eye now. Uh, hold on.
My opinion of your hands off of me, you animal. Me, too. Here,
I'm going to smack you upside the head a little bit. Opinion
today. I'm scared to ask.
Okay. Okay. I think we we're good. Eye is fixed. Eye is now fixed.
Perfect.
We're good. We're good. Now it just look
Important call I got to take, mate. It's almost like the It's
tinted red. Okay. All right. See you.
Okay. What the heck? You fix my lazy eye now. I cannot I cannot.
All right. What else was there around this? I forget what we
were looking at. I We decided to look at this. I can't remember
why. Okay. Oh, yes. What I wanted to do was read I've got two
cases that I might want to read a little bit through. Okay. Cyber
linked me one which is oh you linked this tweet here. Okay. Cyber
link me one which is apparently used to like the basically something
was posted before a certain date. And let me see here. This guy
motion 8. I want to I want to give this a read in just a second.
I'm trying to think of anything else we could talk about here
though. Not totally sure. But this will be what comes up next.
Just give me I'll be right back. Sorry. Use a bathroom and get
some water here. I'm totally bum